we've come to the last coding exercise
in this course now that you've got your
conference central application up and
running i'm going to show you a couple
of things you'll need to do if you want
to write a mobile application to use
your conference api you're going to need
to give your mobile app a client id
regardless of whether you're building an
android app
or an ios app you need a client id
and just like with the web application
you create the client id in the
developer console
you're also going to need to generate
the client libraries for your conference
api so that you can include those
libraries in your mobile application but
what your mobile application chooses to
do with the conference api well
that's up to you
come on then